[Applaudissements]
voir vous allez devoir pour la vérité de
mai mois la boule jaune
voilà vous de jaunouse allait devoir
dire à l'autre mettez-vous là je vois à
dire à l'autre ses trois plus gros
défaut si vous voulez démarrer camille
camille démarré après vous donnera trois
plus grandes avec grand plaisir
premiers pas professionnels ça on s'en
est rendu compte depuis le début du
deuxième
arrogant c'est assez évident et
troisième coureur
sk je n'aime pas ça attendez attendez
attendez avant d'avoir les défauts de
camille est ce coup-ci dans tout c'est
quoi le plus gros défaut de francis gros
défaut de france c'est de connaître
vraiment énervé il est souvent m
ça a été moyennement énervé me dire
qu'ils ont animée musicalement ça
eric c'est quoi son plus gros défaut il
est trop excité quand les deux camps
donc ça va et quels sont les trois
défauts de kamin pas facile vénale non
oui pourquoi il est là quoi on l'avait
mais quoi au final de quoi baver notre
série ltte quoi bon alors que je vous
insinuez par là haut ça ce n'est pas là
que parce que vous comprenez vénale
l'argent mais des vols - simon
prétentieux égoïste à n'importe quoi
parce que ça qu'est mai
il tient je vais donner mon iphone en
plus attention